[Music]
modern agriculture today faces two big
challenges an increased demand for food
and growing more sustainably
the farm to fork strategy at the heart
of the european green deal is helping
with this second objective
more sustainable farming will also make
the food we eat healthier
one of the eu's key farm default
commitments is to reduce by 2030 the
overall use and risk of chemical
pesticides by 50 percent
promoting safer alternatives to
pesticides is a top priority at the
agricultural college
here agricultural experts apply
protocols created by the defease network
a french public initiative that helps
farmers deal with more sustainable
methods of production
some of their actions include tailored
crop strategies ways to avoid products
that pollute and reinforcing plant
immunity with natural biostimulants
a coordinated strategy like this has
direct advantages for the environment
and farmer's health it can also have a
positive impact on economic returns
we have a national database which has
shown that the reduction of pesticides
has no impact on the operating margin
as we use less pesticides we might
expect a smaller yield but there are
less costs in the end the margin is
almost the same
mechanical weeding plays an important
role in soil management this technique
used in specific conditions helps
farmers remove partial amounts of the
herbicides widely used in crop
production
thanks to this method we could reduce
the use of herbicides further to do so
you have to use this machine at the
right time in the right way and with the
right setting so as to not compromise
the development of the crop
within the framework of national and eu
initiatives education also plays an
important role
the students of the agricultural college
represent the next generation of farmers
those who will deal with a more
sustainable way to produce food with new
rules
for them a cultural transformation is
underway even in the rural world
i've got the impression that things are
accelerating before we were much more
focused on pesticides now a lot of
farmers are changing my father is an
organic farmer i know we can grow
produce in a different way
nowadays we should use other methods to
be able to get the same yield
to have a better quality of food
and to preserve our environment our
planet
[Music]
the farm run by the campus carries out
its own crop cultivation and breeding
activities its ultimate goal is to turn
the entire production organic but until
then the current approach is already
improving the quality of the soil and of
the food chain
biology starts in the soil if there's
life in the soil we give life to the
plants and the animals if the plant is
healthy at the beginning the animal will
eat this plant and will produce healthy
milk and meat automatically we consume
this milk and meat and we have healthy
food
[Music]